my name is scott and i've been in
portland forever my whole life since day
one
um and i grew up on the actually let's
see if we turn the lights out actually
maybe in the on this side i grew up in
northeast portland i moved to beaverton
and and hung out with kristen in middle
school
uh and we both became programmers so we
got that going for us
we're the only ones that got off the
tough streets at beaverton
uh
which was cool um now i um
have been blogging for a non-trivial
amount of time and actually if you go
out there and google with bing
for scott
there's a scott sports
scott brand toilet paper these bastards
that it all went south with a restricted
trademark i used to be first like
literally on the home page of google
when you search for scott
and then all of the the other scots came
around and now i'm like second behind
whoever this schmuck is
right 150 years i mean what is that
really right yeah so if you go on google
for scott you know i'm one of the top
scots
in the area
and i blogged before it was called a
blog
and that is kind of my claim to fame
isn't blogging but it's rather not
stopping blogging
so i'm just going to go to my blog
archives i'm going to just hold down the
the space bar
and
look at some of the stuff that i've been
blogging about
so
this is probably going back i want to
say 16 17 18 18 years
and uh
i have a bit of a reputation of being
productive um but that i i don't believe
in hustle culture and i want to talk
about that because a lot of people that
obsess about this kind of stuff and i'm
still going by the way uh get oh and i
also have a a podcast that you should
all listen to my last name is is
hanselman hansel man like hansel and
gretel man
and i have a podcast i have done
uh
come on podcast this will be the one
like 33 years ago
33 years ago i started the podcast right
now
this is
episode 721
and one of the things that's worth
pointing out about my podcast is that
most podcasts no disrespect if you have
a podcast uh are two white guys on skype
talking about javascript
and uh i made a podcast many many many
years ago hundreds of podcasts ago i
want to point out that i'm still
pressing space
uh and i'm having no trouble finding
really qualified women and people of
color isn't that a funny thing with that
pipeline that crazy pipeline problem
that we're having
just a challenge anyway uh having
absolutely no issue putting on a show
for 700 episodes that's every single
thursday for the last 700 episodes so i
got a podcast i got a blog and none of
it's my job
okay
uh so
i tweeted about this because i was like
kind of feeling myself a little bit i
was like hey you know good job for not
quitting
um and someone's like i don't like the
way that you're um
your what was the word that they said i
was like me like the you know the san
francisco bay hustle culture
like always be hustling you know you're
not you're you're your company failed
because you didn't try hard enough
that's [ __ ]
right i don't like that so i'm not
trying to say hey look at me i'm
productive you need to try harder
what i'm saying is that through
focus and deliberate practice and
absolute choice
about what i wanted to be doing at the
time
i was able to do these things while also
having a job
and
that is what i think productivity means
and when people go out and say oh well
you know it's about lists or it's about
this or it's about that i think it's
more about intentionality and more about
what they call deliberate practice is
anyone into deliberate practice and what
that is right it's a kind of it's
productivity plus mindfulness
and being thoughtful like you you don't
get to
watch nine hours of a netflix show and
then wonder why you didn't get anything
done that day now
the alternative flip side of that is
like well i needed that
that time that binge to recharge like i
owed that to myself so it's important
that i and no one ever go and take your
recharging time and make you feel bad
for it like you know why you didn't get
that code done is that nine hours of
watching whatever on netflix that's not
that's like binge shaming right
but at the same time if you complain
about
that nine hours
then you have to ask yourself well maybe
i should have just done seven
and then blogged for two hours or
studied or learned spanish or got my
blue belt or whatever right so what i am
kind of against if i can be against
something is people complaining about
not getting stuff done when they just
kind of like do other they find stuff to
do other stuff someone at work was
saying i don't know how you find time to
blog
and there i was like well you you poop
every day right and they were like well
yeah sometimes twice like twice whoa i
mean that's that's a level of productive
that i would only aspire to
uh that was that's amazing it must be
really important to you
and they were like yeah and i was like
so you do find time for things that are
important
and then and i was like trying to
understand that like to do these things
to talk to people to blog to learn to
whatever is important to me therefore i
make time for it and i set up systems by
which i can be successful a lot of times
when we want to be productive we set up
systems that are guilt systems
that is the exact opposite of what you
want to do you want to set up a success
system that inspires you to succeed
rather than shaming you
does everyone have that big book pile on
their desk and they got like the ruby
way somewhere in the middle of the thing
and then every once in a while you'll
like pick the ruby way up and you'll put
it on top and like this is the time i'm
going to read the ruby ray you know and
it you're never going to read that pile
that book pile is a monument to your
failure
and it sits there every day and you're
like we got it on the ground or it's
here it's whatever and it's just books
you're not going to read and it exists
and there's a tiny little voice in your
head that says you suck
so i realized that rather than having a
pile of books i'm not going to read i
literally let some of them go
and i make small piles of books that i
actually read
like two or three just a reasonable
number and then when they're gone i
actually feel successful and i'm like oh
that was awesome
because it doesn't feel good to read one
book in a pile of 11 but it does feel
one or two out of a pile of one or two
does that make sense so setting
measurable goals right like i don't have
any
uh any illusions that i'm going to be
good at taekwondo but at least i'm going
you know twice a week and that's
important to me and the idea that it's a
marathon whether it be the blog or the
podcast
it looks like a lot of productivity but
let's look at the blog for example
let's go by date let's look at 2019. so
here's the blog going all the way back
to 2002.
okay
so what do we notice about the blog
let's just look
february
march
april may what are we seeing here
twice a week
not four times a week
like do you have a blog your vlog
you should blog five times a week oh my
god i went to this talk enhancement was
great and he skilted me into five times
a week i want to go from zero
to five times a week and that will work
for exactly two and a half days
and you'll miss one and then you're
going to feel bad about yourself and
then your very last blog post that
people visit when they go to your blog
is going to be four years ago
and it's going to be like i know i
haven't blogged lately but i'm
rededicating myself to blogging
right so then you're going to come and
gonna get a job and then i'm gonna
google you and then i'm gonna find that
your last blog post was four years ago
and it was you saying i'm gonna blog
more and it's just then it's a thing
right
so for me
twice a week
was an amount that was like
non-threatening
but what's amazing about that is twice a
week
that's a hundred times a year holy [ __ ]
that's like 100 pages like a book you
know what i mean and 100 times a year
like if you if you give a blog
okay you don't have a blog if you blog
twice a week for 17 years you will be a
moderately successful pacific northwest
technologist in an obscure space of some
renown
like yeah she's like check box right
that's going on my linkedin you know
what i mean
i i told my uh my my dad was like you
know people kind of know you and i was
like i'm kind of the bruce campbell of
programming
five of you laughed because you know who
bruce campbell is and five of you are
like who the [ __ ] is booth campbell
exactly that's me who the hanselman
who's hanselman no because bruce
campbell
bruce campbell it's that guy from that
thing
right he's just he's that character
actor from that thing you know you're
that guy that yeah yeah that's me but
for computers
which means nothing that's not even like
a guest star on law and order so we all
have to like
lower our expectations about what are
doing so then i started thinking about
well who am i doing this for
who am i writing this blog post for
here's the trick though
friends let us
powerpoint powerpoint powerpoint
why am i blogging about stuff the
biggest thing that keeps people from
blogging is this idea that well who am i
what do i know right who am i to blog
about ruby right i did ruby for like
three years when it first came out i did
rails and like rails one
i shouldn't be blogging i don't know i
have no authority of any kind so i did
this blog post i got a 3d printer it's
one of my most popular blog posts ever
the basics of 3d printing from someone
with 16 whole hours experience
i just i just owned it like i have been
3d printing for a weekend
and i just wrote up like the whole
experience and people love that stuff
but who am i writing it for though right
am i like a famous blogger no i get
decent numbers but i'm not like gruber
or one of these people right it's not my
job it's a side hustle
so why
let's say that you email me and you say
uh oh you have a question yes what do
you got
an observation oh no
people looked at that blog because it's
cool it's like when you were
when some of us were that that's cool
you buy the album just because the band
name was clever
okay
so you you like you thought that was a a
good hook
that's i would click
really that's just funny what other
funny things you've got in there
square foot gardening for programmers
that's the thing i actually have that
so let's say that you email me
afterwards and you're like
awesome talk
here's a great question she's got a
great question i go holy crap that was a
great question i'm glad she emailed me
i don't know you right i'm not going to
give you the gift of my keystrokes like
she's had this amazing question oh i
should have thought about that i should
talk
shoot
like i only have so many keystrokes left
like you may be you may feel young but
you have a finite number of keystrokes
left in your hands before you die
how old are you
how fast you type
not very
uh we'll say 60.
you have
207 million keystrokes left
it's going down by the way i just want
to point that out it's actually going
as we sit here
that is
assuming that you live to 90 you have 60
years of typing left that's four hours a
day nothing but typing
that is 67 novels that you could
potentially write so get on that feel
bad 414 medium-sized computer programs
or
a million emails to your boss
okay so she emails me this like super
awesome question and i'm like oh dude
great question um but i'm not going to
give her 2 000 keystrokes like for free
no like not going to happen
where can i put those keystrokes where
can i put them i can put them anywhere
with a url
doesn't matter blog maybe not medium
don't put them in walled gardens because
wild gardens suck but somewhere with a
url and then i email you a link
to that thing and then she sends it to
one friend
i just doubled my keystroke potential
like it's literally that easy
email is where
your keystrokes go to die
they're a huge waste of time nobody
reads your emails nobody prints an email
out and puts it on the wall unless it
has a password in it nobody laminates
like they just emails are just trash
it's dumpster fire for your hands and
your tendons and when your hands start
going when you're old like me you're
gonna regret a lot of those emails so
every single time someone writes you an
email you i love that you're nodding
you're like yes like this is exactly the
thing put it in a knowledge-based
article a wiki
for god's sake sharepoint if you have to
one note
literally anywhere and then send a link
and then if she sends it to two people
or three people or ten if only five
people read your blog
your million keystrokes becomes five
million keystrokes
so i've been doing that for the last 17
years
consistently i don't email people's
stuff
anytime someone has a question
about something like for example if
someone wants to come on my podcast i
realized after about three times that i
kept typing the same crap so i made a
one pager called hansel minute slash get
set guess set up and says hey you're
going to be a guest on our show
and then i realized that i was typing
that url a lot
and then i made an auto hotkey to just
go like shift alt h and then it like
prints out the url like any time this is
the whole point right every time that
you can automate stuff
automate stuff
like seriously dry that's the whole
thing about rails right just don't
repeat yourself don't repeat yourself
don't worry about yourself you see the
irony
so anytime that you can yeah yeah
it's a joke grenade it'll get you a
little bit later
i i'm always slow to laugh no it's
totally fine you were laughing at the
opening i understand it after the
comedian does the riff
there's no that's not weird at all
nothing wrong with that so
i'm not writing the blogs for you or for
the audience in any way and that's the
thing people say well how do why do you
have a podcast how do you pick your
people
well you know how people are always when
they're early in career how many people
early in career here early in career
like less than five years less than 10
years okay cool one of the things that
you're going to want to do a lot is like
call people and ask them to take you to
coffee
i got a minimum number of coffees left
like this i can i could measure coffees
and again i don't mean to overly pivot
on age a little bit but i'm pushing 50
and that gets you thinking right my
dad's like 75. so let's assume he's
around for 20 more years and that's
optimal and he's kosher and i see him
once a week i can measure the number of
lunches we have left that's how you
start thinking at this age so a very
nice young young person says can i
have coffee with you
am i taking that is that a lunch with my
dad is that a lunch with my kids my 14
year old's 14 i got only four years with
that kid that's a 1200 days and he's
gone and i'll probably never talk to him
again
because that's what the kids do right
and that's a problem so how do i scale
something like that give talks write
blog posts do youtubes anything at all
where i can get the word out
mentorship rings i've got a mentorship
group of about 60 people and we go and
we pair off into little groups and then
we meet up so i can
i can't do one-on-one mentoring because
it just doesn't scale but this is my
obsession i recognize that there is
value in singular one-on-one time with
individuals and there are people that i
do have that time with
but if someone says hey can i have
coffee with you early in career
not really now when i was early in
career i wanted to have coffee with all
kinds of cool people but they don't have
time either
but if you tell them would you like to
be on my podcast
they freaking love that so the podcast
has been a long
con
the whole podcast is an excuse for me to
talk to people
that would normally not talk to me this
guy here
just talked to this guy his dad was the
first black software engineer
in america in 1946
just wrote a new york times best-selling
book i would love to freaking have
coffee with this guy but if we all email
him simultaneously and say can we have
coffee why is he going to pick me
but i emailed him and i said would you
like to be in my podcast
and he said well you push my book and i
was like hell yeah i'll push your book
buy the book
i have gotten to talk to all kinds of
cool people
on the show
dhh is in there somewhere
mats
japanese dude
nice nice guy
martin fowler
uh
what's uh where's dhh
hannah how do you spell hannah meyer
oh i went but i must have changed the
thing i talked to martin and david and
hannah meyer-hanson in 2007. again two
people who i have no business talking to
but i had a podcast right you too can
have a podcast i don't matter if no one
listens to it people just they don't ask
no one has ever asked me but how many
people listen to your podcast
oh just me
i just want to have lunch with you and
record record it that's not weird at all
no
it's not you make a good looking page
like this good i honestly have no idea
how many people listen to this show but
i have this wonderful wall of faces and
i literally went to the lawyer just a
couple of days ago and i put together a
digital will to make sure that my
domains and things will remain so with
this will go read only and i will be
gone and
that's
360 hours of somewhat
meaningful content
isn't that cool
so it only takes me about two and a half
hours a week to do the podcast and the
blog it's minimal
so i want you to think about the kinds
of stuff that you want to do and the
kinds of value that you want to provide
and if you're excited about it now i'm
not saying that everyone needs to go and
do this
but i am mindful about it if i choose to
not do a show one week then what is that
what does that mean
do i
do i lose something do i lose momentum
um in this case here if i look at my
calendar
actually i won't bring my calendar
because it's internal um i've got three
podcasts recording at lunchtime on
thursday that'll get three weeks out of
the way so then i can take time off
i actually took off eight weeks and we
lived in south africa last year and i
kept the podcast going because i
pre-recorded shows and then i hired a
person on fiverr to go and like publish
the shows and then i added a little bit
of code to my podcast site
to invalidate the cache and auto publish
the shows on every thursday
now cool
so i can now go up here to
my my little thing here this is the
place where i do my podcasts
and look at episodes
and i've got the green one is coming
next week and i've got the two yellow
ones that are ready to go so i'm up i'm
done for
february
i don't feel
pressure there's no psychic wait
to do that
with me so far
feel free to interrupt
i said psychic weight
let me talk about this a little bit
we'll talk about a little bit about
productivity unless you guys have any
questions or thoughts
you with me are you like you buying what
i'm selling we cool okay cool
blah blah blah this is darth vader on a
cat
just got to keep it frosty make sure
you're paying attention
i've been coding for a very long time
uh some yeah thank you very much the one
true way uh that was i was actually
programming three years by the time i
started that i actually wrote the first
diabetes management system on a palm
pilot
uh i did it in 4k
that's literally enough you could you
could print memory out
and put it on the ground and stand on a
chair and see all 4k
and be like oh there's like a bite there
that's wrong that's literally that's how
much you had this was awesome like just
like just because it's fun to talk about
old stuff you see that circle
that was the first time anyone ever
drawn a circle on a palm pilot
any so my early in career people ain't
boot camp people here
why would that be interesting like oh he
drew a circle yay
right what do you need to draw a circle
what kind of thing do you need boot camp
people to draw a circle
you need radius you need math
yeah
math does not exist in a palm pilot
no
palm pilots only have integers
they have 8-bit integers
so how do you get a decimal point
on an 8-bit integer
well you cut it in half and you say
everything in the middle
left is going to be on the left of the
decimal point everything on the right of
the decimal point is going to be on the
other side of the decimal point so you
basically pretend
that a an unsigned integer is
in fact cut in half and you treat it as
a float
and then you go and find out that you
don't have kine sine or cosine or the
ability to do any kind of math like that
and the screen is only 160 by 160. so
instead i made a constant array that
represented the biggest screen i could
imagine any computer could ever have
one thousand by one thousand and i made
a one thousand
hard-coded
i generated it like at a command line
and then pasted in a constant integer
that represented a circle
and then held it in in memory there and
then shrunk it down to the size of the
screen because you know what what device
could ever have more than a thousand
pixels is madness
um
and then drew a circle it was crazy like
that was the best thing i've ever done
in compute 30 years of programming like
nothing makes you like you just like
i stand up never done that before in any
programmers just like you're at home and
you're hanging out with your partner and
you're just like
[Laughter]
right and you're like
and they're just like
don't care
whatever this is i'm excited for you i'm
glad that you're glad
that you drew a circle right
yeah my wife is a nurse she just doesn't
care
okay
i've written all kinds of stuff we
talked about that i wrote about being a
phony that was great if you google for
phony my face shows up which is fun
um
this is a picture of my son ignoring the
light that i put up that would indicate
that i was on a call
yeah it is very nice
i've talked about kids
and programming square foot gardening
for programmers
building your own arcade cabinet
before and after shot
uh god help me i wrote an app for the
windows phone um
i have a game called baby smash don't
have any babies
uh it's not for smashing babies it's for
the baby to smash the keyboard and like
stuff happens and that's open source
yeah it's super awesome so we got babies
like rock on my baby's 14 which is uh
problematic uh i wrote a bunch of books
that are trash
um
i i'm working on a book right now called
relationship hacks
about being married being in a mixed
marriage
where you have a geek and a normal
person
how you deal with that
talk about the podcast
i have a couple podcasts i got another
one called this developer's life
that is nothing at all like this
american life in no way i have to say
that for legal reasons
i did one on pop culture called ratchet
and the geek
i've got a video you can download if
you're interested get involved in tech
it's a two-hour free documentary about
getting involved in tech blogging
twitter stack overflow conferences user
groups stuff like that do all of this
because i enjoy it
yay oh when i went to microsoft actually
people said i was a sellout because i
started in open source back in the early
90s i was like a big open source person
and i went to microsoft people like
you're such a sellout i think it really
made me feel sad like that hurt my
feelings
but some
somehow i was able to work through those
uh those feelings
that's a picture of me before microsoft
is me after microsoft
worked out pretty well
okay
so a lot of this is just advice right so
like feel free if you don't like the
advice you don't need to take any like
okay um
this actor that you don't know
back in the day went and asked a
question of this other actor that you
don't know
and said how do you write a movie script
and he said you get some paper you put
in a typewriter you type fade in
and you keep typing
[Laughter]
that's the way productivity advice was
given in the in the in the 60s and 70s
but if you want to scale yourself you
got to go back to the basics you got to
get down to computer science right
the less stuff you do
the more you can do like if you do
nothing
you can do it infinitely
that's a really good quote i'm gonna
make that a quote okay that's now a
famous quote
here's a graph that proves that if you
do nothing it has high throughput
extremely high throughput uh nothing now
there was a time when you could know all
the information right you could know
everything because there was like
basically two books but now everything's
just one thousand plus does anyone have
like 30 40 50 000 items in their inbox
and their iphone and you don't even like
see it anymore
like it is like the little the little
badge
it's like fifty thousand you just don't
care like you could turn the badge off
right like it's telling you that you
suck and you just don't care you're like
i'm never going to read those emails
just control a archive just so they
don't they don't like they're not
teasing you
now when i was developing software in
the 80s there was no internet there were
these two books
and that was the sum total of all
information so it was really easy to
focus because you would sit down in the
basement with these two books
and then if you had a question you could
put it on either phytonet you can google
that or you could use all actually lycos
and then you could go on a bbs ask a
question and then in about four or five
weeks someone would answer you
and go i also have that question
right the only kind of comparable
feeling for the young people for you to
have is have you ever like posted a
question then years later googled found
yourself asking the question and there's
still no answer
that is like true loneliness you know
what i mean like just the profound depth
of loneliness but now we have people
being interrupted all the time right
people are constantly being interrupted
and we find ourselves in these
situations
where we feel like we're failing
and what i am trying to do is to make
people talk about that
there is no safe place at big co
nike intel microsoft google facebook
amazon whatever to go and talk to your
co-worker and say i feel like a failure
because they are keeping the fact that
they feel like a failure to themselves
and we all just pretend like we're all
just crushing it
and then we go home
and then we say you know i'm just going
to work late a little bit just to catch
up because you know it's a busy time
like february kind of time frame that
february march it's just february march
april kind of you know may june july
august kind of like just the september
october november you know january
february march kind of time frame
is busy and once i get past that over
the hump
it'll be awesome right
and then we hope that things will work
out but hope is not a strategy
and no one talks about it so what i've
broken down is a couple of concepts from
stephen covey a couple of concepts from
david allen
and synthesized them into a system that
helps me get centered and be deliberate
in my practice now i give this talk all
over the world
and every time i go to a new place i put
the word for the thing i'm about to talk
about in the language
uh the thing that's interesting though
anyone speak a non-english language
what you got
japanese uh what's the word for
effectiveness in japanese
think about that you can google it if
you need to
okay what's the word for efficiency in
japanese
okay google those pic google those two
words for me who else had another
foreign language what you got
effectiveness efficiency what are the
words in hindi
okay you check that anyone else any
other languages
what you'll find is for many many
languages
it's the same word
so even for english speakers what's the
differences between effectiveness and
efficiency in english
well i don't know is it
he says not a lot anyone got a
definition for effectiveness and
efficiency
even as a native english speaker what do
you got
you're not just doing something but
you're doing it
in the minimum amount of time and effort
which one's that efficiency or
effectiveness
that's efficiency for you effectiveness
is more like
it achieves its purpose in the end oh
that's good i like that that's good
stuff so i call it like this
effectiveness is doing right things
setting a target it's goal oriented
i'm going to run a race
which direction do i run
that's the finish line i will run that
way very effective running this way
would be somewhat ineffective
efficiency is doing things in an
economical way
so once i've picked my direction now i'm
going to haul ass
but if you go and translate like in
spanish they'll literally put the same
words together the japanese have the
same yeah
yeah so it they they mixed it
you'll find this in many many languages
this is how i like to phrase it so
that's a good take a picture shot
efficiency doing the right things
no effectiveness yeah i did it myself
see how hard this is this is important
effectiveness is doing the right things
i am an effective person at this task
and then efficiency doing things right
good stuff is this effective
depends
he jumped the wrong way
how do we make these decisions though we
have all this crap coming into our lives
all this information that's coming in
and it needs to be triaged i love
language i love looking at language and
parsing it out do you know where this
word is from what language that's from
because english steals everything
french
exactly
it's a word that means to sift to
separate but you can dig more into that
when we think about triage what do we
really think about we think about war
zombies
apocalypse
toe tags
white when it gets when the stuff goes
down and you know that there aren't a
lot of software engineers on the walking
dead
so think about your skill set i'm just
saying
there wasn't a guy in the walking dead
that was like quick i need someone to
reboot the router and then i was like i
can do it
no they want you to chop things and lift
things so we're all dead
unless you have a skill
i saw there's a utility kilt around here
somewhere and that guy's probably got
like a knife
so there's potential you don't have a
knife no
you're supposed to
you're supposed to have a knife in your
spawn
yeah
utility man utility like if all of us i
thought it was going to be you you're
going to die and
next time it might be too late
so when stuff goes down how do you
triage it well triage is very effective
you're on the battlefield and you say
are you dead are you walking wounded get
off my battlefield you're fine
you have to be aggressive when you're
going to survive a war like that you
have to do the same thing with your
email you know that one email that
you've had in your inbox that's so
important so very important that you
haven't answered it yet because you need
to give it the time it deserves in order
to answer it
and it will just sit there and it's been
there you ever have an email from like
last august
you need it there it has to be there
because it will be answered it's
important
that person may die i've actually had
this happen people will die
and i felt bad i never got back to them
and like now that email bounces which is
super sad so answer emails or just
declare that you're not going to do it
be aggressive
there's work that comes into your life
and david allen thinks about it like
this there's predefined work work that
you have set up ahead of time like we're
going to paint the house this weekend
there's work as it appears like quick do
this that work just appeared
and then there's the work of defining
work the work that we don't do
is defining work does anyone have a
meeting on their calendar
anywhere at all in the week to figure
out what the hell you're doing
what do you got that's great i love that
what do you got
mondays wednesdays when do you meet and
talk
just by yourself or do you have people
there
rock on superstar love that what do you
got
day prep when you do it
every day or like once a week
whoa saturday day prep
that is impressive very no i mean
that's awesome
it sounds small but there's a moment
there when you you just need to go
what the hell am i doing
busyness
is kind of an illusion and it's also a
form of laziness
being overly busy is a kind of laziness
we'll talk about that
when you have some work then the only
things you can do to it is do it drop it
delegate it give it to somebody else or
uh defer it don't do it now if you take
david allen's ds and you take stephen
covey's uh productivity urgency
important stuff and you overlay the two
so this is merging two productivity
concepts importance on your vertical
axis urgency across the horizontal axis
things that are both urgent and
important houses on fire
babies coming do it now
build is broken website down do it now
things that are neither urgent nor
important dump it
if something's super super important but
not yet currently on fire
planning meeting
awesome
until it becomes a problem
like i'll give you an example of a thing
that's currently in my head
i've got this blog had it for a few
years
i thought it was on a virtual machine
didn't think about it i got a free
hosting deal
years ago from a company called orcsweb
they never sent me a bill
it's been 17 years
nothing's happened
forgot my password decided to go and
find out what's going on
works web doesn't exist anymore
my blog still exists though
how is that a thing turns out orcs web
got bought by a french company
and nor quebec close enough and they
bought all that stuff so i was like oh
okay fine my virtual machine is in
quebec cool rock on hey can you send me
a copy of my virtual machine so i can
run it in like a proper cloud i don't i
can't do quebec but they're like oh i'm
so sorry i saw the old hardware okay
well that's cool where is it oh it's
right here
what do you mean right here no it's
under my desk
i'm on the phone with francois and they
literally took some of the servers from
the acquisition and they just shoved it
under his desk it's never been on a
virtual machine
he can touch it
like he can put his hand on the hard
drive i can push refresh in oregon oh
that was you
that's not okay
you know what the mtbf is right and we
know what mtbf stands for
mean time before failure how long do
hard drives last
five years
my thing's been on the same hard drive
for 17 years this is a huge problem
in the back of my mind it was down here
and now it's slowly making its way over
here
it's not quite urgent but here's the
deal
one day it's gonna be pretty [ __ ]
urgent
and i'm like freaking out because i have
to go and like move the whole thing and
this is like 15 16 17 year old software
like i'm running dot net you know 2.0
and like that's nine dot nets ago
and i've and the whole thing is done in
xml so like
uh
and i you know because you know it was
the time like we didn't know what we
were doing kids we just we thought it
was a good idea
it will rise again my friend you think
that curly braces are where it's at no
man angle brackets right it's the same
thing
no you all think that jason is cute it's
not cute still just xml but with curly
braces so that's another conversation
yaml the curly braces you can't see them
they're still there
it's totally still there again no i'm
going to be like old man who shakes
fistic cloud and that's fine you know
what i mean they're going to just roll
me out and i'll be like actually how was
the way
[Laughter]
sgml where's my dtds look all that stuff
up
xml
xml it i was probably one of the big
fans of that product
point is
this is becoming very very urgent
and actually i have one xml file for
each blog post so there's like 47 000
you know xml it's a whole thing
so
what is currently in preparation phase
is soon to become a crisis
but things that are not important but
still super fun to do interruptions
interruptions are so fun you know why
people like interruptions interruptions
are a drug
interruptions are pseudo
important they make you feel
oh i have to take this call i'm sorry
i'm very important
your phone your all the little vibration
all the little notifications oh
that's all just hiccups hiccups in your
life slowing you down you think that
usain bolt runs as fast as he can and
then gets like a little vibration on his
watch and he's like oh look at that you
can't sprint full on if you're being
interrupted turn all that [ __ ] off all
the notifications all the toast remember
when skype was an app that we would
actually use to talk to people and that
was just a thing that reminds me of
strangers birthdays just like random i
got so-and-so's birthday you skyped
eight years ago like thank you skype
that little piece of toast that like
pops up or like comes in from the side
like i was coding and oh
what am i doing where do i work what's
my password
all those things slow you down
no joke
urgency
twitter great example
this is a picture of a mouse with an
electrical wire in his brain
and he just has to pull on this little
lever to refresh the serotonin refresh
that sense of positivity that sense of
i'm okay just just pull to refresh just
pull to refresh it gets a feeling that
i'm going to be all right then i'm going
to be okay you have to catch yourself in
those moments
when you're scrolling idly
through facebook or through instagram
and ask yourself is this doing anything
for me
other than improving my serotonin
if it does improve your serotonin that's
great
just know that it is acknowledge that it
is remember when
if you see that's the other that's a
great i love that you brought that up
because
like we went to middle school together
right
um
do you ever like go through facebook or
whatever and you're like oh i'm gonna go
to facebook yeah oh they're on a jet oh
i'm not on a jet
like it's like it's a system literally
designed to make me feel bad about
myself
and i'm not even really friends with
those people like we hung out like on
new year's eve because we're friends but
the other like friends
i don't hang out with them like i see
them on facebook oh you got a baby like
good for you like
i haven't seen them in 25 years i just
don't care so i got to let it go
remember when jesus
uh had the whole thing with the two with
the fit the footprints remember you're
walking on the beach and there's only
that's when he unfollowed you on twitter
that's why there's one there's only one
set of footprints because he's like you
tweet too much you need to stop
any system that can succeed has flow
control if you know anything about tcp
or you've learned about this kind of
stuff you'll know that like 20 or 30
percent of your packets are being
dropped
that's okay communication by its nature
is fault tolerant that's why people can
call each other multiple times why
texting is asynchronous
dropping the ball is the right answer
for your mental health for your getting
stuff done unless you are this guy and
that's your job don't just just drop
stuff you don't need to do those things
here is a guy surfboarding in the space
on a crocodile
stay focused people
now
when we think about our well-being and
our health and our anxiety and those
kinds of things i came up with this term
called psychic weight um does anyone
remember when when tivos came out there
was like like a recording called dvrs
right
right like there was a moment like
remember anyone you're how old are you
you're probably like 30. okay did you
ever you remember like making an
appointment to watch tv like let's all
get together on thursday and like watch
tv are you the last generation that will
ever do that right like my kids they
don't like seinfeld thursdays at eight
and they all get together and they watch
it appointment tv
then one day the tivo happened and then
there was like the law and order channel
and you don't know what you're doing
like law and order click i want to watch
that episode well click click i'll just
watch them all then you come back and
there's like 97 episodes of law and
order and then you're like what was a
joy
what was the greatest thing since god
talked to moses is now a to-do list of
things that you're never going to do
i have never seen the wire
i am tol i know
i'm told it's very good
but it's a commitment
it's like seven seasons we're talking
about like 40 or 50 hours of my life and
i have to be conscientious
about
is that 50 hours the ones i need are
that is that going to help my anxiety am
i going to be able to get something out
of it
the psychic weight of the tivo
literally was causing my wife and i to
put the kids down early
i'll be like okay we'll put him down
early i'll call in sick tomorrow we're
just going to bang through dexter and
we're going to get it done and then it's
done or of course the dexter finale was
just a dumpster fire so like just forget
that the last season ever happened just
stop at john lithgow
point is
letting things go is the number one tool
that you can have for your mental health
and your sense of productivity saying no
to your co-workers to your friends to
your family
is how you stay sane so you say positive
oh i wish that i had more more time in
the day how do you have so much time in
like 27 hours i get the same number of
hours you have
what are the things that you're doing
what is the 24 hour like chart every 20
minutes and ask yourself what did i do
during that time and say was that
value-add could i get out of that and
then you'll get yourself another 90
minutes a day now here's the thing
though here's the problem
i like television
a lot
but i can't spend that kind of time so
what's some feasible multitasking what
could i do
what success system could i set up where
i might be able to watch the tv that i
want i just binged on october faction
fantastic show 10 hours
what could i do
and also watch tv
work out bingo i made a deal with myself
that i'm only allowed to watch tv when
i'm on the treadmill
one more episode that's one more hour
that's three more miles
that's the trick that's the trick actual
feasible multitasking being able to set
that up allowed me to be conscious and
focused about that
catching myself in bed on my side with
the iphone
going like is this my life now is this
what we're doing this is a thing now
if that's what you need if that's what
you need to recharge do it but do it
intentionally does that make sense
now my buddy jd meyer
gettingresults.com has this idea of the
rule of three everyone's heard of a
version of this rule the idea is
that everyone's got these lists of [ __ ]
to do
and
it's too big
the only thing that we can really do is
three things so if you have three things
of varying scope
what could you do tomorrow to set
yourself up for success
and do three things where you would feel
so awesome about it
like rather you ever go home just
feeling bad like i don't even know what
i did today like i fixed the build what
was that
and then you just go all right i'm just
gonna do better tomorrow and then each
day is just more piles of crap like that
what could you do with your three things
that you could do before lunch you could
do two of them before lunch and one in
the afternoon and be like i just crushed
my day
in order to pick three you have to say
no to a bunch then you expand the scope
and you have three things for the week
and then three things for the year
two to this young lady's example
monday make a plan make a meeting with
yourself 9 a.m what's your vision for
the week
friday reflection how did it go what
worked what didn't and reflection has to
also turn into forgiveness
yeah [ __ ] this week up was not awesome
did my best this is some things that
didn't work out i got interrupted the
build happened my website went down and
i totally didn't do xyz
own it
move on and monday is a new week to
start all over again you're not going to
answer those emails you're just never
going to answer them control a
archive they're not going anywhere
they're just not in your inbox
totally serious now remember i said that
busy is a form of laziness
it's because
busy
overtly busy overly busy oh i'm far too
busy to have to be
very important that kind of busy
is non-deliberate
i'm so busy because i'm just
putting fires out
i really respect when i have a boss or a
person who's important in my life at my
work
actually sit down and hang out with me
so that example that i made before about
you answer you asked me a really great
question
it's not that i'm too busy to hang out
with you
we don't we don't we're not like that
you're not my mentee or uh you're not my
my person i'm in a relationship
therefore i am choosing to consciously
protect myself and prioritize
i will give you the gift of my
keystrokes because what a great question
every good question every good technical
question is a gift because every one of
them is a potential blog post
so if i go to my to-do list
i use the to-do app microsoft to do it
used to be wunderlist
these are all
blog post ideas
every single time someone says hey blog
something i throw it in there i will
never run out of stuff to blog about
then i go to my day i click on the idea
button and i say i could do that and i
could do that
and i could do that and i make a very
small list and i check those things off
there's always a backlog this is agile
as applied to your life makes sense
it's the intentionality that we fail to
do in my opinion now you ever like go
hang out with your friends and there's
someone who's not around and they're not
around for like a while and then out of
nowhere they popped back and they like
wrote a book or did a pdf or made a
whole business or made a website holy
[ __ ] that was amazing
because being creative is the opposite
of hanging out
now in in high school we used to hang
out like super late like 2 a.m 3 a.m
because we had fomo
right fear of missing out
because every time you would not hang
out late you would you were like someone
oh dude after you left whoa
like the hologram of prince came and
they did a whole set it was amazing
never happens never ever happens
think about yourself if you want to hang
out with them in the lobby of the hotel
until 2am and see what happens cool but
do it with intention but that four hours
that five hours it's easy to blow time
like that hanging out with people
would have made you more successful on
your test and your boot camp in that
open source project you're working on or
whatever
we live in a very complicated time right
now it's easy to have a lot of malaise
someone is always wrong on the internet
you're not going to change their vote
it's not going to happen they're going
to believe what they're going to believe
and no one's like oh my god
i was going to vote for so-and-so but
then i saw this tweet
that turned the tide of the election for
me because of that tweet thank god that
person in bed on their side on their
iphone three in the morning just could
not sleep and then tweeted that thing
that i saw
let it go
here's some homework for you
take uh this list this is just my list
your list is going to be different
identify the streams of crap that come
into your life and inboxes and about
email and inbox about everything it
could be your property taxes it could be
a ticket to a concert or a broadway show
that you're going to go to it could be
physical it could be virtual take it
identify the streams and sort them
signal versus noise
this is mine
now i like talking on the phone i like
face time i like synchronous
communication with humans when i'm
stressed out though this is the sorted
list this is the least important that's
the most important i draw a line
and the way i make up time the way i
free up time to work on the stuff i want
to work on is by dropping stuff you know
how we always do out of office emails
you ever have someone do like an out of
office email they're not really out of
office or just like here's my out of
office thing to tell you i'm too busy to
answer email
people do that for work but they never
do that for personal
do that
make it personal out of office and just
say i'm not answering for the next month
i'm writing a book i got a thing i'm
working out i'm doing my black belt or
whatever
i'm not going to watch tv i'm going to
make these things go away and that's how
you get one two three five hours a day
that's how you make these hours appear
um this is huge if you have any kind of
an email situation this was the biggest
email rule game changer
i would encourage you if you have
outlook or anything like that in your
life
i have 240 emails here notice that
two-thirds of them are in an inbox
called cc'd
the young people can go and look up what
a carbon copier is
i
put the c-seed stuff stuff where i'm not
too
in another inbox
and i only check it once a week
fyi this isn't do a task this is fyi
game changer cut my email down by two
thirds now you might say well my boss
has a tendency to put stuff on cc that i
need to do
don't do it
only has to happen once
you train people
how to treat you
they will learn oh okay so if it's
important put you on two cool handled
make sense
now here's a real challenge
unless your job like your linkedin is
like emailer that's like your title
try this tomorrow don't check email in
the morning
don't roll out of bed and check your
tweets
you don't get to yes sir
yeah any notification slack whatever i
want you to do this for me and try it
out you can tweet me later let me know
how it worked
don't respond to any notifications until
noon
and what's going to happen is you're not
going to know what to freaking do to
yourself you're not you're going to like
ah
you we don't even know how to poop
without a phone
like that's where we're at right now
so
what's your job
what do you want to get done tomorrow on
wednesday
you don't get to check any notifications
in the morning put your phone in your
pocket put it on airplane mode airplane
mode works on the ground
shocker it's a thing
do not put energy into things you don't
want more of you know how when you're
just starting out early in career people
are going to have this happen you're
going to be on the slack you're going to
get these notifications at two in the
morning on a sunday and you're going to
reply
you just taught your boss that you're
that person
you just taught them that that is the
boundary slack teams outlook they all
have do not disturb my phone goes into
do not disturb at seven o'clock i'm even
using screen time on my iphone to dim
apps
that i don't want to be using you should
also do that
use the same child controls to block
yourself from doing stuff that is
unhealthy that you would do to a child
that makes sense
and we talked about keystrokes
blah blah blah blah blah skipping
skipping skipping oh physical stuff
oh work sprints anyone do pomodoro
you know where the pomodoro is pomodoro
pomodoro
a pomodoro is like i think it's italian
for tomato it's a little tomato timer
and it goes for 25 minutes
think of it as a unit of time someone
says hey can you do this little bit of
code for me yeah it's about two
pomodoros
it's about an hour
you get five minutes to pee
you've got to do this thing you've got
to do it once without
stopping at a sprint what can you do for
25 minutes without doing anything else
you focus on the task
try that it's really freaking hard
you'll find yourself at reddit you'll
alt tab to other random places and all
of a sudden you're going to be like i
don't know i'm on reddit now i was
writing code and now i'm looking at cats
how i don't know what happened right
sprints this is just agile applied to
yourself
think about the things that happened
during that sprint that 25 minutes did
you interrupt yourself
did you get anxious did someone
interrupt you did you get called write
it down
sprint again and see if you can reduce
that number of interruptions lower
here is uh p herman saving some snakes
from a fire
there are internal interruptions
like you're just hanging out and you're
just like whoa i said i'm playing
solitaire and i'm like really good at
solitaire
and then there's external interruptions
where like your boss is like hello
the reason that we interrupt ourselves
is that we think we're going to miss out
on something
for a lot of us like 9 11 was a thing
that we were like when that happened it
changed how we thought about news and a
lot of us spend a lot of time like
what's going on what's happening like is
the world ending like climate change has
got me stressed out but did it whatever
it is happen
and i missed it
if we can really acknowledge to
ourselves that everything that is
important will find itself to you many
times
did you hear about whatever you'll hear
someone will tell you you don't need to
go and check whatever the news website
is and refresh it
stay in your flow catch yourself in that
runner's high whatever that is while you
are coding or knitting or whatever makes
you happy
focus on wrapping yourself up in the
thing that captures your attention and
you'll feel like this guy
i think this is really interesting when
people think that multitasking is a
thing
speaking on the phone to talk to humans
synchronously computer science the
optimal number of threads in any system
is one as soon as you multitask you have
to context switch and if you context
switch that's a load you've just lowered
you know three percent five percent ten
percent here is a really good example of
a
bad multitasker
you know we call them an organ right
organ donors
seriously that's that's awful
put your phone in the trunk
focus on what you're doing
the only true multitasking is this
his eyes are moving too i worked really
hard on that gif
remember i talked about guilt systems
don't set them up
blah blah blah blah blah blah
so stuff you don't need to see some
suggestions rescue time anyone use
rescue time it's a lovely app runs in
the background and will chart and graph
the app in front
if you don't know you're on reddit or
you're wherever you're not supposed to
be and you care you can't cut it out of
your life unless you measure it what's a
healthy amount of time [ __ ] around
online
no i disagree that's hustle that's a
hustle mentality and we reject that
yeah do you that's why you succeed
um
this this was interesting to me uh where
i was noticing
that i was messing around from 1 to 4
a.m every day
i didn't know that
that sucks don't do that
i needed to see the chart to know it was
a bad idea
this year was interesting this was a
monday where i did nothing
that's where my appendix burst
not a huge deal
what's wrong with tuesday though
you did anything at all
exactly i was in the hospital
in outlook
the next day
and then
working on wednesday
very dumb you gotta see the chart to go
wow that is not the chart i would have
expected to see
now we talk about physical things
i'll try to wrap it up really quickly
here um physical things that tickle your
brain oh yeah that thing right there's
all kinds of physical stuff that come
into your life like we have uh tickets
to the broadway portland broadway thing
right you like buy it once a year and
then the tickets show up and they're
pretty random and we don't even we're
like literally like what are we doing
this weekend oh crap we have tickets to
fill in the roof or whatever we forget
about these tickets and then again you
gotta go looking for the tickets like
where are they and they're in the drawer
with all the usb cables or whatever
what you can do is you do 43 folders
12 folders for the month
31 folders for the days you make a
circular buffer so right now we are on
what what is today the fourth so you'd
have four
five six seven that all the way to 28
then you'd have march
april may whatever and then as the days
and the months move you take it and you
move it to the back so if i get a ticket
for something in april i pick it up i
stick it in april and i forget about it
and then when april comes back around i
open it up
works for any physical thing only takes
up this much space you get one of the
little suitcase filing cabinet deals at
home depot that's the sum total of all
paper in your house period bills it
makes everything go away
isn't that cool
speaking of paper my dad who's trying
he's a firefighter and he's not
technical and he was really struggling
with the whole ipad thing
um and you know keeping it charged and
all that kind of stuff so we just made
him one
three by five three by five cards you go
to hipster pda it's an actual thing it's
google hipster pda and you print out
this stuff and you get one of those big
snappy
deals and he puts it in his back pocket
it's got retina display infinite battery
makes him feel very comfortable and he's
got the things that he wants to do just
handled
not joking people forget paper paper's
where it's at when you're stressed out
when you're freaking out i know about
you we all have our our thing that we do
when we are anxious
if i'm overwhelmed
i clean my room
take everything off my desk and put it
back on my desk and i get a haircut
i've accomplished nothing but at least
i've got the hair
and the desk handled
if you're really stressed out
you can't figure it out by looking at an
11 inch macbook air you just can't
you got to get a big old piece of
butcher paper or something and you go
okay i was stressed out about my year i
printed out 12 calendars and i looked at
them and i said okay i can see i can
stand up and look at my year
if you do that with an 11 inch macbook
air you just end up being really far
away from a screen you can't see
find a whiteboard paint a whiteboard
paint a wall in your house with a
whiteboard with the whiteboard or the
chalkboard paint and go what the hell am
i doing we actually did that one better
and i would recommend that you do this
as well does anyone have a dac board in
their house
no oh i love you people
look at this kids
go
to goodwill
and buy a 20 monitor it's got to be
1080p take a raspberry pi you all have
one lying around go and install the dac
board software you shove the raspberry
pi in the back of the monitor
and it loads up
opens chrome goes full screen and auto
refreshes every five minutes
has my google calendar has family
pictures the weather
it is beautiful sir it is beautiful and
because i'm that nerd
because i'm that nerd
i actually have my blood sugar because
i'm a type 1 diabetic
on a screen in the house in a picture
frame so when i'm remote they can see my
medical implants that show my blood
sugar in the cloud and tell that daddy's
okay even when i'm in another country
that then is a rest api for my own body
which then shows up
on the raspberry pi which i can then
mount it is freaking awesome yes i love
that you're excited about it no one else
cares you bastards
you can then rotate it put
you know like art
paintings put it in like a cool frame
if you're really cool go on google for
magic mirror
you get one-way glass
and then it's a mirror and then you walk
in front of it and a motion detector and
then it's like oh space you know it's
like
arnold schwarzenegger in the mars movie
or whatever right telling you and
all this stuff totally free
that seriously i got that at goodwill
like i'm a goodwill all the time if you
go check out my instagram feed my
instagram feed it's literally me at
goodwill
it sounds silly but it's like literally
that's all i do
like i found this palm pilot goodwill
this is a dreamcast that i got recently
at goodwill
i modded it to support um
i modded the green dreamcast and i i put
an sd card inside it which is kind of
badass if i may say so i'm like oh it's
a dreamcast what sd card
um
this you know kind of stuff that you
have on an instagram it's all meant to
make you feel good about yourself
right don't you look at my my my
instagram and you're just like what is
he doing
bunnies good stuff
yeah i'm winning at life man it's all
just it's there to make people that went
to high school with feel bad about
themselves
um
it's just meant to make you feel better
this is a quote that i like but i don't
like all of it it says if it's not
helping me make money it's not improving
my life in some way it's mental clutter
i'm going to remove the money part
if it's not helping me to blank
whatever blank is
improve your relationships get promoted
at work learn how to code whatever i
want you to take all the things in your
life
sort them
measure them it can be toxic
relationships it can be your roommate it
could be the tv show that you're never
going to finish
is it moving you towards your goal if
it's not out
that's it
and here's the deal though
willpower is a well that has to be
replenished this is not hustle
culture i'm not telling you you need to
try harder you need to work harder what
you need to do is you wake up every
morning in a place of forgiveness
say yeah okay yesterday sucked but today
is a day to do it all over again
and i said what i'm gonna do today i'm
gonna have a salad instead of instead of
two burritos that's what i'm gonna do
after this
i'm not going to eat the entire bag of
chips you can actually ask for baby
chips at chipotle just say i want the
baby chips and then you won't eat an
entire bag of chips because that's 1200
calories
just say baby chips they keep them
underneath the counter it's a
carbohydrate little tip for you there
i'd like a burrito and baby chips it's
kind of like getting a double whopper
and a diet coke kind of that
that bit of irony
here's your homework
sort your sources think about work
sprints go and look about look onto the
pomodoro technique
anything that distracts you anything
just go into your iphone or your android
phone and settings notifications turn
them all off
the only notifications i care about is
like the alarm for the house
i'm trying to think like the house on
fire or like my wife texts me
speaking of texts you can go into your
phone and you can make it not buzz for
anybody except important people i did
that i went to my faves they beat my
phone
randos don't beat my phone
turn all that [ __ ] off you will not know
what to do with the quiet
then go look at your personal toolbox
and consider the tools that you're using
consider a tool like rescue time etc
and then of course follow me on twitter
uh and now i've taken up a little bit of
your time sir
well no i mean you had some stuff to
talk about anyway
that's my spiel there's like another
hour there i could do like a whole
workshop but do you get like why it's
such a great time to be a programmer
right now and how we can go out and kick
ass tomorrow
and only one person left
and i judged him quietly but i said
nothing
when he left and he probably left
because this wasn't feeding his spirit
and that's okay
that's a great reason see that's
freaking awesome someone actually got
mad at me because i don't want to go to
the ukraine to talk to 250 programmers
and he was we're going back and forth he
was being all sassy i'm like dude it's
the ukraine like it's like going to take
me two days to get there
oh but we love you here in the ukraine
and i said dude
365 days a year
four more years of my 14 year old it's
gonna take me seven days now is it as is
it a summertime i could take my son with
me that would be awesome i'll take him
with me well no it's in april
during when oh it's during spring break
i'm not going to your conference like
i'd love to but no
saying no so yes going home to see the
babies before bed apps freaking lutely
hell yeah i love that that's what i
that's my whole thing right now
dig it
any questions comments thoughts anyone
disagree with anything anything i said
or think any feedback or i can make this
suck less
sure deep work by cal newport goes into
a lot of this stuff okay deep work
all right that was the revolution for me
and essentially yes atomic habit
essentialism excellent i dig it are you
doing those things though so both of you
know those things so so this was all
like old school for you no this is great
everybody has their own take on some of
these ideas
you got to do it that's the thing and
then you gotta understand that you're
not gonna do it all the time
and then you gotta forgive yourself and
then just do it the next day
cool
do you wanna do your thing
i would love to do my thing excellent i
will unplug and i will release this to
you